hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology
and let me see we have all kinds of
questions here
IMM asks do we know what the first piece
of technology was
well what is technology technology is
somehow taking things that exist in the
world and setting them up so that they
can be applied for human purposes
so the real question is how did people
sort of
there were just the pure humans like you
know the Naked Animals so to speak
running around and then there are things
humans made use of from the outside
world to do things like for example they
might have made uh you know Flint axes
they might have made pieces of clothing
they might have made things like that I
would think that probably the first
thing one might reasonably think of as
technology was probably things like uh
axes where you know you're taking a
stone and you're like a flint for
example and you're napping just hitting
the the Flint with another Flint to kind
of make it so that eventually by the
nature of that kind of stone eventually
you can get these sharp edges which you
can then use as a way to go you know
attack Critters or whatever else one
wants to do so I think that's probably
this sort of
first example but now this question of
was something a piece of technology or
not people might argue about this in
great at a great length because like you
find rocks to arranged in a particular
way in some you know paleothic uh
archaeological site was that a
technologically set up thing was that
for a purpose or did those rocks just
happen to be thrown in those places
likewise it's kind of like these cave
pictures where you know there are lots
of at least there's some caves where
there are just a bunch of hand prints
are those handprints just randomly put
there just because somebody was like you
know I don't know having a party and
thought it would be amusing to just put
their you know put their hand dip their
hand and paint and stick it on the wall
or was there some great significance to
the arrangement of those handprints that
sort of a question of was that
technology or was it not was that
something that was set up for a purpose
or not or not
and I think the same
when one looks at things that various
kinds of uh non-human animals do you can
ask the question you know is that
technology is the Beaver Dam a piece of
technology uh it's at least potentially
Beaver Technology even if it's not human
technology or then you could ask well
you know is the is the silk that's spun
by a silkworm well that's perhaps
technology for the silkworm but it also
turns out to be technology for humans
because humans can make use of that Silk
as well
so and or you know more extremely you
know the trunk of a tree is presumably
something where you know the tree is
assembling that for the purpose of
getting its leaves up high and all that
kind of thing
but also we humans can make use of that
so I think it's a it's a complicated
question but I would say that the um uh
of the things we know about
some of the earliest kinds of things
will be things like you know Stone axes
and so on
um that's that's probably very early
examples of taking something from The
World At Large and kind of customizing
it for for human purposes
let me see
uh
I'm a little bit uh I see a whole bunch
of interesting questions here there's
one from Aaron that I just noticed so
Alan Turing had not died at the age of
41 let's see was he 41 he was born in
1912 and he died in 1954.
so uh give or take yeah 40 that that
kind of age
um
if Alan Turing had not died in his early
40s what might he have worked on during
the remainder of his life
you know
one thing about anchoring is he was a
a sequential project guy he worked on
something he worked on you know he
finished it and then he kind of moved on
to a different thing he was not there's
some people were the Arc of their
careers involves kind of there's the big
thing you're building and it's kind of
and that's going to span Decades of life
and then there are other cases where
it's more like you do a thing and then
you see another interesting problem you
go work on that that takes a few years
then you've got to see another
interesting problem you work on that
Alan Turing was more of that second kind
rather than of the first kind of the
giant Arc of uh of activities so you
know in his life he had worked on things
like the central limit theorem that was
one of his early projects of proving the
central limit theorem that's something
that John Von Neumann when he wrote a
recommendation letter for touring that's
the thing he mentioned in the
recommendation letter not the universal
turing machine paper
and uh you know I don't think Alan
Turing thought that
his paper about
computational universality I mean its
official title in 1936 paper on
computable numbers with an application
to the end scheiden's problem
uh the insurance problem was the
decision problem of Hilbert that is the
question of if you've got
some
uh
can you can you determine by mechanical
means whether some specified statement
some specified logical statement is true
or not like for example a statement
might be this particular equation
involving integers has no Solutions
is there a mechanical procedure for
deciding if that's true
well I think you know when Alan Turing
wrote his paper that led to the idea of
Turing machines and Universal
computation
it's not he didn't think it was that big
a deal
also because he had this model of
computing that um was sort of based on
the operation that bank clerks have of
you know he was kind of idealizing what
bank clerks do of you know you kind of
take something from old old Bank clerks
before there were computers and so on
um you take something from one Ledger
and you go look at and you put it on
another Ledger and you do this and do
that he kind of imitated and idealized
that and the tape for a turing machine
it's kind of interesting to look at that
because I'm about to be working on
Observer Theory which is kind of a way
of idealizing the operation of an
observer much as Alan Turing tried to
idealize the operation of a computer and
by computer I mean a person who did
computation which was the only example
of a thing that did computation back in
those days but anyway it's he I think it
was not clear he didn't think of that
paper as being having the kind of
dramatic importance that's turned out to
have
but you know in the Arc of turing's life
he then ended up working on um uh
cryptanalysis during World War II on
kind of the the things that led to
information Theory I think and then he
worked on other stuff he worked on the
Practical programming of the Mark II
computer in Manchester
um they're like no the the Ace in
Manchester
um
and uh
early electronic computer and so we have
you know computer documentation as
written by Alan Turing and we have uh
coding as done by Alan Turing he was a
pretty hacky coder
and then he got interested in
theoretical biology and he was
interested in the Philo taxes the you
know how leaves grow out of the shoot of
a of a growing plant and uh you know he
had this thing where possibly this thing
that's one often hears from applied
mathematicians and so on consider a
spherical cow I think might come from
Alan Turing who is interested in the
dappling patterns on cows and how they
would be generated from reaction
diffusion equations but he as an
approximation considered the cow to be
spherical but it's very notable when he
worked on theoretical biology in the
early 1950s he didn't even imagine that
one might use Turing machines as models
for that he just went straight to
partial differential equations from kind
of standard mathematical physics
and and then he had other things you
know he'd worked on chess playing
machines uh with his uh
um
uh
uh friend Champion what was Champion's
first name I can't remember uh David
Champion maybe
um
the uh The Chaperone was a friend of
tourings as a as a student Champion
owned himself later became a fairly
well-known Economist
um I and but but he was a person with
whom Alan Turing worked on you know
chess playing machines and Alan Turing
worked on you know having a mechanical
device to compute the uh uh the zeta
function and managed to compute further
in the room the data function that
people had been able to do before
and in 1950 famously he wrote his paper
about kind of AI
that was sort of informed by his turing
machine work
um but was more by that point informed
by the fact that there was starting to
be actual electronic computers which
were in a sense informed by Turing
machines but by a rather circuitous
route of Von Neumann having been
interested in neural networks and
McCulloch and Pitt's work in 1943
mccullochum Pitts relied on turing's
work in 1936 as their evidence that a
McCulloch pits neural net could really
do Universal computation and they then
sort of assumed that Universal
computation was kind of the big story of
computing things that would be what
brains would be able to do
but I think by the time Alan Turing was
working on on sort of AI and the Turing
test and so on he was more thinking of
practical electronic computers of the
kind that he was by then using
so what would you have done next
he was interested in physics he didn't
know that much about physics but he was
interested in physics and he was
interested in kind of foundational
questions and and I wouldn't be that
surprised if he wouldn't have worked on
uh kind of trying to find sort of more
fundamental ways to think about physics
of the kind that I've spent a bunch of
effort on
um I think you know Alan Turing never
simulated a turing machine
maybe he would have done that if he'd
done that he probably would have
discovered a bunch of things that I
discovered in the 1980s about what
simple programs do
he was more you know in his construction
of his Universal turing machine in 1936
he was much more of a can we as
Engineers so to speak make a machine
that has all of these sort of
capabilities of doing Universal
computation he was not given the concept
of a turing machine hey let's just start
enumerating Turing machines you knew you
could enumerate Turing machines that was
actually important to his argument the
fact that you could specify a turing
machine as ultimately an integer was
something that was important to him
because he had to be able to give the
specification of a turing machine as
data to another turing machine so he had
to know that it was possible to give the
specification or turing machine as a
number and therefore as something which
could be enumerated in fact that was
also important to his argument about the
decision problem the undecidability of
the decision problem and the diagonal
argument that he gave for that so he
knew that Turing machines were
enumeratable as numbers but I don't
think he ever imagined the idea you
should actually look at machines one two
three four five up to a million or
something he didn't think of that he
certainly had the technical capability
by the end of his life to be able to use
a computer to look at those things we
never looked at them those things were
looked at around 1960 actually by people
like Marvin Minsky who enumerated the
first 4096 Turing machines they're just
the ones with two states and two colors
and uh found that they didn't do
anything interesting he has a quote in
his book about finite and infinite
machines that he published in the mid
1960s that says about very simple Turing
machines that um the uh
the kind of analysis of these 4096
Turing machines is laborious and best
carried out with a computer but
um uh the um uh that it is unpublished
and unpublishable on the grounds there's
just two monotonous and uh sort of
automated to be interesting but anyway
Alan Turing never did that
you know my own guess
would be that Alan Turing would have
been would have gotten into the into
sort of computer entrepreneurism
to some non-trivial extent I think he
was a a person you know he was sort of
an academic but he bounced around
between kind of working at sort of the
emerging computer center in Manchester
kind of being a fellow of this Cambridge
College kind of being involved with the
national physical laboratory in London
uh and in the war he was involved with
Blackberry Park which was after all the
military research organization I think
he was not a sort of died in the wool
kind of I'm going to be a professor all
my life kind of person I think he was
more a project by project kind of person
and I think he would have been very
likely drawn into kind of early computer
entrepreneurism
um and I think uh as one could see that
sort of happening in his work on the
Manchester computer
um I think he was frustrated by working
on projects which other where other
people were in charge I'm not sure how
much he would have been I think his
immediate self-image would not have been
that he would have been able to be in
charge of something although my guess is
he would have been successful at that
um I think that he would possibly have
gotten involved in you know more kind of
sort of public Outreach kinds of things
particularly if he'd kind of lived
through the 1980s and so on I mean he
was not well known until probably the
1990s actually
um and you know he was a person where
people had heard of Turing machines but
that was kind of a geeky thing in
theoretical computer science as
Bletchley Park and the activities during
World War II got Declassified he became
a bit more heroic in that regard
um then kind of had a a boost with
Andrew Hodges
um biography and um
kind of uh in the end being sort of an
icon of gay rights for for a while
um that sort of I think boosted his
general public visibility
um and uh uh now some of that some of
that might be uh kind of uh you know he
he died uh by eating an apple poisonous
cyanide and it's coming a long debate of
you know did he kill himself was he um
uh was he poisoned by somebody or was it
an accident I have to say my uh I think
the likelihood that he killed himself I
believe the likelihood that is very low
uh I know a bunch of people who knew him
I've talked to them extensively about
this to quote one of them if Alan were
going to be if Alan had intended to kill
himself he would have written a whole
book about it
um it wasn't uh I think that's a very
unlikely possibility but you know part
of the myth has to do with the fact that
you know there was a lot of kind of I
would say non-gay rights kind of stuff
that went on that we would now think of
as totally crazy
um and uh you know but the truth uh from
these people I know who knew Alan Turing
is that that stuff he thought that stuff
was kind of crazy but it didn't really
profoundly bother him certainly not to
the point where he was going to kill
himself over it and um uh the so but but
that was part of his public visibility
now has been associated with that
essentially connection to that uh that
sort of you know Marta type aspect so if
you take that out of the picture and you
imagine what would have happened with
Turing if he had lived
um another you know 40 years or
something 50 years
um and uh you know he probably wouldn't
have I don't know whether he what level
of public Fame he would have achieved
probably it would have depended on well
probably a certain amount more for his
scripture analysis work during the war
um I think he was and I think he would
have been pulled a bit more into kind of
the the public Outreach Arena uh like
his radio broadcast from 1950 about some
which led to the Turing test idea
um I think my guess is he would have
worked on a series of well there's a
there's an interesting problem can I
work on this there's an interesting
problem can I work on it I think some in
physics I think he might very well have
wound up doing uh you know starting a
company in some form or another at least
being involved in a company that was
starting
um and uh
um I think he probably would have tried
writing a bunch of software whether he
would have done that successfully I
don't know he was not a person who was
he was a person who was very clean
thinking when it came to core ideas he
was not particularly clean thinking when
it came to things like notation and
presentation I mean interestingly he did
write a paper once I don't think it was
published but it's in his collected
works about mathematical notation kind
of musing on issues of kind of how
that's set up
and I think uh you know one could
imagine he was certainly interested in
mathematics one could imagine him trying
to write um
uh kind of mathematically oriented
software and so on
um I don't think he would have been a
great user level designer I think he
would have been good at understanding
what the sort of the core point was but
not so much at making something which
other people could readily understand
although it has to be said that the
exposition in his papers is quite good
although the notation is quite often
quite uh obscure I mean in the original
paper about Universal Computing he has
what he calls Greek letters and what he
calls German letters which are gothic
script kinds of things and the whole
thing gets very very Gothic maybe in his
handwriting it wouldn't have looked so
bad but by the time it's typeset the
thing is pretty uh
um or you know pretty difficult looking
anyway that's a thought on that
um
let's see
uh
you know the the question I think I've
written things about Alan Turing
particularly in connection with the
Centenary of his birth in in 2012 and uh
I I have to say that there have an awful
lot of things that Alan Turing was
interested in that I'd been interested
in too and uh there's a certain sense in
which well if Alan Turing had lived
longer he would have done all the things
that I've had the fun of doing
um before I did them and and so uh you
know then he would have built a platform
on which people like me would have been
able to operate uh and do do different
kinds of things probably but there's a
certain argument that a bunch of things
I mean I've been sort of amazed when I
found Alan turing's paper about
mathematical notation it's like oh my
gosh I've written about that too
um they're just an awful lot of things
and you know he wrote about things like
could you take the contents of
Encyclopedia Britannica and encode it
for a computer and how difficult would
that be and he had an estimate of how
difficult that would be in a sense that
thing is like wolf from alpha or these
days I
actually it'd be interesting to look
back at his estimate I did look at his
estimate relative to the effort that it
took to build wolf malpha and he was
overly pessimistic and how difficult it
would be to make sort of extract the
computable data from the world it's an
interesting question relative to the
training for an llm you know he didn't
think about at that time you know it's a
loop that didn't close actually
from Alan Turing came mccullochum Pitts
and neural Nets I don't believe that
Alan Turing closed that Loop and thought
about neural Nets
um I think I don't think that Loop ever
closed I think he was really thinking
about Ai and the context of more kind of
symbolic uh kinds of computation and
things a bit more like Turing machines
but in any case the um uh you know I
have been a bit shocked at the extent to
which things that Alan Turing had was
interested in and wrote about are things
that I've ended up also being interested
in
um I know that
um uh well in
um uh just a whole collection of cases
or like combinators something I was
interested in I find out Alan Jordan was
interested in those too
um so I I don't know what uh what one
can deduce from that but um uh uh you
know there's I think the the the key
point is that Alan Turing was interested
in foundational things and so have I
been and he was interested in kind of
formalizing things in a certain kind of
way and so have I been and uh that that
has led to some overlap in the kinds of
interests because well there's perhaps
uh uh you know you're concentrating on
the foundations of fields like
mathematics and and uh and so on and
that's kind of only there's sort of One
path down in those cases
um
boy Des is asking what about if Von
Neumann had lived longer Von Neumann
died at the age of uh died in 1957
and he was in his 50s I think
um
you know Von Neumann
was
a very quick Off the Mark
uh again not so much of a large projects
person more of a problem-solving kind of
person and
you know by the end of his life he was
doing an awful lot of work for the US
Military and an awful lot of work for uh
computer companies basically
um and uh
I would suspect that those are the
directions that he would have more gone
in than in kind of diving in to another
sort of area of basic science I think he
was much more you know he was a
commissioner of the atomic energy
commission and he was um uh kind of a
key consultant to IBM and he was uh uh a
sort of major figure in the in the whole
military Cold War kind of story
um and I think that's uh
um uh that's kind of um
a um a place some
uh my guess is that's more the direction
that he would have gone in
um than sort of diving into other areas
basic science I'm sure you know at the
time when he died well okay there was
one area of basic science he was working
on which is this kind of computer in the
brain theory of self-reproducing
automata these kinds of things
um so you know he might have pushed her
on that more because he was interested
in that and
you know whether he would have uh you
know push them hard enough to get to
deep learning and so on I don't know
um the computers didn't really quite
exist then to be able to do that but
also the the kind of the will to realize
that high dimensional deep learning High
dimensional neural network learning was
going to work in the end even when sort
of the low dimensional toy models
weren't necessarily going to work I
don't know if one only would have
realized that I would I would bet
against it
um I think you know he was a person who
was very good at at problem solving with
certain tools of mathematics and so on
uh that he knew and and kind of logical
thinking and so on but he had a habit of
of kind of missing the point on the kind
of deeper issues of you know not really
understanding Universal computation
until that it kind of um uh you know I
mentioned he didn't really understand
Alan turing's original 1936 paper until
years later he didn't really understand
you know he didn't he was working on the
foundations of math but he didn't
conceptualize the idea of girdle's
theorem uh you know he had a formulation
of quantum mechanics which I think in
the Long View of History will have been
seen to have kind of elighted a bunch of
things about measurement that confused
people a lot
um but but uh uh you know but on the
other hand you know you find his his uh
fingerprints in all kinds of fields like
if you go to Metallurgy and you look at
things like you know what's the average
number of of um uh um
a collection of soap bubbles you know
what's the average number of sides to a
uh a soap bubble well you you get work
from Von Neiman in a place like that you
find you know you find his
his kind of uh him touching an awful lot
of areas and adding a certain kind of
mathematical problem solving to those
areas
um and that that's I think his his
primarily mode of operation
um
let's see
uh
I'll be asked sasks who was the first
what was the first time when statistics
was used to predict something
you know statistics the word
means comes from kind of features of the
state
by state one means State as in thing run
by government or something it's kind of
like what are the sort of
aspects of
the kind of aggregate characterization
of the State of the State so to speak
I think John Grant is the person who is
usually credited with having had the
first kind of aggregation of that kind
he had a book in the 1600s called bills
of mortality rather grimly which was a
description during the play I would
guess uh 1665 maybe that plague in
London it was the Grim list of how did
people die
and uh where did they die which which
boroughs in London were this number of
people dying in it was kind of an early
uh kind of um way of aggregating those
kinds of things now of course even
Antiquity there'd been plenty of
censuses of kind of uh you know count
the people in this place or that place
but primarily the the purpose of that
counting was to you know Levy taxes and
to figure out you know how much tax
should there be on this side of the
other thing but I think that was more of
a I I don't think that and I think it
was more like okay King here's a bunch
of tax rather than okay King there's 11
312 people living in this part of the
Kingdom Etc et cetera et cetera I think
that that wasn't uh so much a thing in
Antiquity anyway the thing that's
usually attributed is the first kind of
statistics of well I suppose John Grant
also did things like making averages and
so on working out the mean you know the
average number of people who died in a
given week or something
um those kinds of things but I don't
think that that was a time when there
were predictions going on I think that
was more to stay here's how it is
um I think there were
things oh gosh by the 1800s and so on
there was lots of visualization going on
people like William Playfair has the um
what's it called uh
this kind of atlas of
um
statistical Breviary maybe I'm not sure
but but um it's kind of an atlas of um
uh
of features of the world like the um uh
you know the summary of the number of
grain imports from this country to that
country over the last 50 years those
kinds of things
but I don't think he ever predicted I
don't think he extrapolated from the
data that was there
um so you know I think that was more
here's how it has been rather than and
from this picture we can now predict
what will come next
um
you know I suppose that the early
predictions of things I mean even in
Babylonian times there was kind of
here's the position of this planet we
can predict where it will be next but
that wasn't really a statistical
prediction that was more a um uh
something that was sort of purported to
be a mathematical calculation of what
would come next
um
you know I'm wondering I mean in other
places where statistics arose
you know when Gauss discovered the
asteroid Series in 1800 I think
um there was all kinds of sort of
telescope errors of of uh of kind of
what you see and that's what led to the
gaussian distribution and so on and uh
but that wasn't again really that wasn't
a prediction of what will come next that
was more just a if you make many
measurements this will be the
distribution of errors in those
measurements
um
I'm trying to think the uh uh certainly
well
then there were people like
paid us
um again I think there was around 1900
the um
oh my gosh what's the person's name
because with L I can't remember it but
um a person in France who was um
analyzing the kind of random motion of
stock prices on the Paris Stock Exchange
about the same time as brown in motion
was being analyzed and kind of looking
at the uh uh that those random Wiggles
but I think that that was more a hero
the statistics of those Wiggles not so
now we know that grain prices are going
to go up
um
the
there was sort of a long tradition of
so-called technical trading by the time
there were those kinds of trading charts
and so on people sometimes they got
called chartists
um would be people who would look at the
charts and say it wiggled up down up
down up so it's going to keep going up
that was kind of a a particular
configuration a lot of those
configurations got names that were kind
of the you know really their random
walks in some first you know very good
approximation but yet you can kind of
see just like the constellation of stars
you can see there's a you know there's a
um an arrangement that looks like a duck
there and um you know you can see it in
the Stars just as it is a human pattern
matching thing and so similarly in the
somewhat random walk of stock prices you
could see those kinds of things and and
lots of people had uh still do sort of
take very seriously those kinds of
things and there's there's a lot of you
know Fibonacci based kind of uh
observations of you know uh kind of
Fibonacci like sequences in The Wiggles
of stock prices and so on and people
make trades based on those and those are
cases where they are in some sense
predicting uh maybe not so much from
statistics as from sort of fitting some
kind of model
uh similarly with with time series and
so on
um you know it's kind of like can you
extrapolate this time series and are you
doing that by the statistics of what's
happened or are you doing it by some
kind of you know a very common time
series prediction is an auto regressive
model uh like an auto regressive moving
average or armor model where you're
looking at essentially making an
equation for what the curve is doing
that is a deterministic equation that
will predict what's coming next more so
perhaps than something where you are
saying from statistics this is the sort
of this is the distribution of what will
come next it's more we've almost got a
model for what's happening let's just
use it
um I would say that uh
gosh I'm thinking in um by the time we
get to
things like World War II and the
operations research that was done at
that time again I would say not so much
statistical prediction uh more that's
you know use linear programming to
figure out if you make this number of
widgets in this place and how many
widgets do you need for that and so on
um
you know in econometrics
which developed
uh people like Morgenstern Von Neumann
people like that were involved but there
were
gosh I don't actually know
um
who were the kind of leading lights of
that field I think those two were
definitely very involved in the kind of
Statistics applied to economic
indicators
and uh now does one make predictions
from those statistics
um I
certainly in modern times people do that
I mean in in you know in the end the
story of Quant Finance is a story of
kind of using statistics to make
predictions and that's something that
really didn't develop in serious form
until the 1960s 1970s even 1980s of um
uh kind of statistical Arbitrage and the
whole kind of uh well that's again
uh you know it's it's kind of use
statistics on existing data take bets uh
you know see what consequences those
have and so on
um I mean I'm trying to think I'm I'm
wondering whether there were sort of
Quant Traders
um perhaps in the technical trading
chartist kind of crowd uh from much much
longer ago but one doesn't necessarily
know that because it's just like well
so-and-so managed to make a bunch of
money but they're not going to tell
anybody how they did it type thing
um very interesting question I don't I
don't um
I'm kind of uh
thinking
I mean no certainly
yeah I think there may have been
political arguments that were made on
the basis of statistical results and
perhaps in the early part of the 20th
century
um
that might have been a thing
um I mean suddenly it happens today uh
but um I think that might have
originated much longer ago there
um
let's see
oh gosh so many interesting questions
here I see Michael here asking
commenting they recently watched the
Oppenheimer movie and seeing portrayed
Einstein girl in Oppenheimer at this
small Lake
so I realized that barely any relevant
theoretical insights in the last decades
especially content to 100 years ago what
does this mean for the science the next
hundred years I dispute the claim that
there are not great theoretical insights
in the last few decades
um I I even think I'd been involved in a
bunch of them but one won't know they
were great theoretical insights for
decades more and uh you know it's only
in retrospect that one could see yeah
that was an amazingly great thing you
know at the time when girdle's theorem
was
developed in 1931 it was it was a thing
but how big it really might have been
and the fact that it sort of backed into
the idea of computation
nobody could see that at the time
the fact that General activity from 1915
turned out to be a big thing in the sort
of definitive theory of space-time at
least until recently
um again was not something that was
known it wasn't until the 1960s that
really the serious significance of that
became clear
so it's very hard to assess what will be
significant until quite a long time
afterwards I think that in our current
times I would like to claim that our
physics project for example and the
things around it and multi-computation
the whole sort of development of the
computational Paradigm the exploration
of the computational universe now all
these uh sort of discoveries about what
LMS can do and so on these are Big deals
these are certainly as big as what was
out and about 100 years ago I mean I I
happen to think that there was a period
of of rapid growth in physics around the
time of the development of quantum
mechanics in 1920s and so on
um there was a the development of
computation in the 1930s I think the
kinds of things that we have now with
our physics project uh will make
certainly the developments in physics we
kind of that's sort of the direct
follow-on to what happened 100 years ago
is what we are now doing and it is a
similar kind of step to the step that
was taken 100 years ago I also think
when it comes to meta mathematics
uh there's been a long fallow period
when not a lot of foundational things
have been figured out I think my own
efforts and kind of the physicalization
of metamatics are another step to kind
of a direct follow-on from what happened
in the 1930s and so on
um to uh in that field I think that we
we're not yet there yet but in you know
biology for example there are a boatload
more facts that we've accumulated in the
last uh half century or so there isn't
yet Theory my guess is there will be
um and it will be big and there really
has never been a theory of biology well
they're really two theories in biology
natural selection and the idea of sort
of digital
nature of DNA you know the central dogma
and so on of uh and that whole kind of
assembly of ideas that center around the
sort of digital nature of genetic
information
but you know there will be big theories
there too
um and those are things which are I
think emerging and will emerge from the
kind of formalism that for example has
been exposed in our physics project and
there's this then this separate Branch
as I say about things like llms and AIS
and so on I think what we're going to
see in the physics and the in the
science of the next hundred years
is they're sort of science
sort of builds up higher and higher
levels of abstraction and that's kind of
how one gets to talk about bigger and
bigger things I think that this kind of
idea of well the ideas of computation
that's getting absorbed not fully
absorbed yet phenomena like
computational irreducibility definitely
not fully absorbed even though it's 40
years old now
um the uh
kind of the computational foundations of
fundamental physics that's really very
new you know three years old or
something
um that's going to be something that
gradually gets more and more absorbed
and what that means both in terms of our
understanding of physics and our way of
exporting kind of the developments of
physics to and the results of physics to
other fields to distributed computing to
biology to linguistics
to you know economics and so on there's
I think there's going to be sort of
dramatic progress as a result of these
really to me these two kind of paradigms
the computational Paradigm and the
multi-computational Paradigm and I
suspect that that the computational
Paradigm kind of unlocks a bunch of
kinds of modeling that we weren't able
to do that we now are the
multi-computational Paradigm is is now
at the point where it starts to be able
to unlock a lot of questions about what
really is the theory of natural
selection how does it really work how do
we make a theoretical framework that
explains how species work and how the
Tree of Life Works and so on in
economics how do we really make a theory
that tells us things about how kind of
the network of transactions in an
economy leads to all the phenomenology
it leads to and so on and you know those
have been places where we've sort of
been blocked from having a theoretical
approach I suspect that the whole
multi-computation idea will give one a
theoretical approach to the those things
and and these will be a very fertile
time I mean in the next probably decade
or so is probably the time when the more
progress will get made in the in the
theoreticalization so to speak of a
bunch of fields like biology and
economics that have been made in in many
hundreds of years in the past so I think
we are far from it being a time when
sort of nothing interesting is happening
this will be a time as happened 100
years ago when physics and
metamathamatics and well the emergence
of computation and so on that was that
was a very fertile time this will be
another very fertile time for these
kinds of theoretical Sciences you know I
have to say I worked at The Institute
for advanced study which is where the
pond you mentioned is located and I
worked there in the early 1980s
um and uh the pawn was not looking the
same in the movie as it did in when I
knew it in the 1980s it was looking a
lot more Main now I don't know whether
that's because I haven't I haven't been
to that pond since the 1980s so I can't
speak to um uh
um
what was happening with the pond today I
assumed that the movie did not go back
and recreate the pond of the 1930s so I
assume that's the pond as it is today
which is looking a bit mangy
um but in any case and there used to be
a lot when in my time there were a bunch
of ducks that hung out on that pond I
don't think I saw any ducks in the movie
but who's to know
um I think
uh in
you know it's interesting because by the
uh
well
you know the 1930s was kind of the the
late side the later side the
developments and things like
metamathamics and quantum mechanics and
so on and uh we're not we're still on
the early side of the uh 21st century
kind of burst of activity in in the
formalization of science I think
um
oh my
the
gosh so many questions and I'm I'm
skipping ahead to ones that are coming
in here internet asks where do you see
applied psychology in a decade is the
quantification of behavior and thought
going to be a shift as advertised
you know I think llms are The Big Break
for things like applied psychology I
think that
they behave in surprisingly human-like
ways
they're ways in which they're not very
human but if you kind of look at them
there are a lot of things about the way
Learning Works the way reasoning works
the way kind of we deal with common
sense and so on
that I think are well modeled by llams
we don't understand how llams work there
isn't yet an llm psychology there will
be there isn't yet an llm science I've
been starting to pick away at that and
hopefully other people will will do this
too
um as one tries to understand what is
the kind of narrative that one can tell
about why does the llm do this or that
thing why does it why is it the case
that if you give the LM too much kind of
uh training data at the end and you
don't kind of repeat things that learned
before why does it get confused and
obsessed with the new data and so on
it's kind of like cramming for the test
it only remembers that or something you
know why does that really happen why is
it able to do kind of you know zero shot
or few shot learning of kind of being
able to be told you know act like a such
and such and it can suddenly be in
character doing that how does that work
and you know how do how do these things
work well the Llama is kind of a lab
where there are no you know there's no
um uh institutional review board at
least yet that tells you you know the
ethics of doing an experiment on an llm
you're free to experiment with it and
take it apart and see what it's doing
now making a narrative science from that
that's not an easy thing to do and it
needs new ideas about how to kind of
make formalizations in science maybe
some of what we've learned from the
physics project and the whole
multi-computation idea may be helpful
for that but I think it's still a very
challenging thing
um so I think that's that's kind of in
my opinion that's the big break for
Psychology and Neuroscience
um that one didn't really see coming one
now has a model so to speak that one can
explore in much more detail
I would say that in terms of the can you
predict what the humans will do I mean
the other thing that's of course coming
is much more data about what's actually
going on in brains and much more
detailed recording of neural activity
and so on and you know we have 100
billion neurons in our brains and being
able you know there will come a time
when by some feat of signal processing
and this that and the other one will be
able to just have this giant readout of
what are these 100 billion neurons
actually doing at every moment now you
say well that isn't that amazing then
we've solved neuroscience and psychology
well not quite I mean we could get a a
display of every gate and you know
hundreds of billions of gates in our
computers
um in the microprocessors of our
computers we'd say what's happening with
all of these gates at every moment in
time but still understanding what's
really going on from that microscopic
data is very challenging it's kind of
like the ultimate example you know if
you're trying to decompile something
reverse engineer something you've got
the machine code but what did it come
from what were the functions that
compiled into that machine code what was
the kind of human understanding of what
was happening what was the bigger
narrative picture about what did this
program do rather than just what are all
the bits that if run on the machine will
work in this particular way so this this
idea of making a larger kind of
narrative structure being able to
explain things that's a non-trivial
problem it's a problem uh you know we
have the sort of of the very accessible
example of nlms we have the less
accessible example of recording data
from human brains and so on
um and uh you know we have the the the
opportunity with llms to sort of to poke
them and sort of feed data into them I
did a little bit of that in in um uh
piece that I wrote recently about some
mental imagery of alien Minds
um as called for the internal team as we
were kind of producing this um the uh
it was called the cat post because it's
got a lot of pictures of cats in it
um but uh in any case the um uh the
thing that um
um
is uh uh so
you know we get to do experiments on
alarms that we can't do on brains
um uh you know in terms of the big
picture of predicting human behavior
um I think it needs a different kind of
formalism we now have sort of the raw
experiments later or we will have it in
the case of brains we we could have at
any time we want it in the case of LMS
and now the question is you know can we
make a sort of higher level formalism
that tells us things that are of
narrative relevance as opposed to just
absolutely microscopic information
that we can't say much from I mean it's
kind of like in the case of physics we
can talk about the detailed pattern of
the atoms of space but it tells us
nothing about kind of the overall
behavior of I don't know some
gravitational waves coming out from
black hole mergers or something that's a
many many levels above kind of the
microscopic detail of kind of how the
molecules or the atoms of space or
something are bouncing around
let's see uh gosh many questions here
let me just see if this
one or two I can cover fairly quickly he
says
um
lady Jay asks can you discuss the
history of cellular automata
oh my I was just looking at that
for the nth time recently in connection
with the historical piece that I'm
writing right now
uh you know first of all what are
cellular automata array of cells each
cell has a color say black or white
there's a rule that says how to update
the color of the cell based on the
colors of its neighbors on step before
okay that's a very
you know that idea has been reinvented a
zillion times
uh the earliest inventions
certainly in the 1950s possibly much
earlier than that I mean there are
examples one could sort of say you know
even kind of Pascal's triangle from the
1600s or before is a little bit like
that it's an array of numbers and you
kind of take two numbers and you add
them up you take Pascal's triangle mod
two you have a very fine cellular
automaton rule 90.
um the you know there are things like
that
I would say that
the kind of one big question is what was
it thought to be good for
and you know I reinvented Cellular
automata in the beginning of the 1980s
uh I didn't know they had the name
cellular automation that certainly
wasn't their only name I mean they were
called variously iterative arrays
tessellation structures homogeneous
structures
um automorphisms or or um
yeah automorphisms of the shift map
automorphism the shift they had all
kinds of names nonlinear feedback shift
registers are very closely related many
different names the same concept each of
those names reveals a different origin
story so to speak I mean my choice to
call them cellular automata which maybe
wasn't the best thing kind of sort of
reflects back to An Origin story that
was associated with John Von Neumann and
Stan ulam
um in the 19 uh early 1950s where sort
of the the the challenge was uh come on
make a kind of a theoretical model of
biologists before DNA was known and so
on come on sort of idealized biology and
John Von Neumann have been trained as a
chemical engineer so his first kind of
idealization of a biological system was
let's have it be like a chemical Factory
and
um then I think Oscar Morgenstern
convinced him that no you didn't really
need sort of all of the continuous
numbers it was enough to just have sort
of discreet Minecraft like sort of
factory construction
and then Stan ulam who'd worked on
infinite matrices kind of convinced him
no no you can just do the
two-dimensional case he didn't get to
the one-dimensional case stanulla
actually tried to kind of invent a
one-dimensional case I don't know why he
didn't um I I knew Standalone but I
don't think I ever asked him this
question because I don't think I'd read
his Works carefully enough at the time
when I knew him to be able to formulate
this question properly but um for some
reason he never thought of just the very
simple thing that I ended up doing to
make one-dimensional cellular
automatically had some elaborate thing
with long-range connections and so on I
think probably because his intuition was
fundamentally if you had something that
simple it would never do anything
interesting which was also Von Neiman's
intuition and pretty much everybody's
intuition including mine
um you know I was lucky enough to
actually sort of use the the kind of
telescope computational telescope to
look into the this kind of computational
Universe of possible programs and was I
would say a decent enough empirical
scientist that when I saw something
absolutely bizarre that I didn't
understand instead of just ignoring it
well I admit it took me a couple of
years to not ignore it
um I eventually realized it was an
important thing
but uh so you know part of the origin
story was John Von Neumann theory of
self-reproducing automata the actual
name cellular automata was coined by a
person called Arthur Burks who I knew
um who uh had been a kind of an
assistant of John Ron Neumann's at the
time of the um uh The Institute for
advanced study computer project Von
Neumann's computer project
um Arthur Burks and one of those
interesting career choices said uh you
know Von Neiman had offered him you know
a a longer term fancier job I think at
The Institute and he's like no no I
don't want to work on this computer
stuff I want to do something real I want
to work on philosophy and so he kind of
became a philosopher I mean later on
sort of a philosopher of computation and
so on he had a bunch of students who
went on to do interesting things in kind
of the the intersection between kind of
philosophical thinking and computation
but anyway it's sort of one of those
career choices of I don't want to do
computers I want to do philosophy
um which certainly is a is a uh well
Millennia long philosophy is a
millennial long story
um that probably you know isn't going to
get sold at any time soon
um but although I think we can have
different things to say on the basis of
these kind of computational paradigms
but I think
um
what uh art books was the person who
coined the terms cellular automaton
um I think at the beginning of the 1960s
or maybe the late 1950s
again
many places there were many models
people have made which was sort of like
cellular automata I've gone on a variety
of wild goose chases trying to find
where people said I think somebody told
me there was a model like that like
there was one that I was about to wild
goose chase again uh a person called
Henry stommel who was a oceanographer it
was claimed by a person called Ed
fretkin that um Henry stommel had told
him that cellular automata had been
invented in studying sand dunes in the
1930s
okay I haven't managed to find that I
mean Ed told me a bunch of things that
weren't quite sort of true and this may
have been one of them
um but uh in any case a lot of sort of
pseudo origin stories like that
um you know the John Von Neumann
creation of sort of direction of
cellular automata and these kinds of
idealized models of biological systems
um that became in the 19th uh 50s late
50s and early 60s it became a story of
can we connect cellular automata as
models of computation to touring
machines well yes endless papers about
that then this idea of self-reproducing
automata and the kind of the theory of
self-reproduction and where would that
get used and I think it was a sign of
the times that there was an awful lot of
you know it was a time when space was
really big uh early 60s and so on and uh
it was very much like there was
self-reviews and lunar factories was one
kind of idea of take this kind of
cellular automaton idea and figure out
how to use it to make a kind of
minecraft-esque kind of self-reproducing
lunar Factory so there were branches
like that a quite different branch which
is actually closer to one-dimensional
Cellular automata that um uh well one
piece of that was non-linear feedback
shift registers so shift registers are a
very natural construct once you have
electronics and you have kind of a a set
of sort of electronic elements that you
can put in a sequence and then you can
have a shift register is you're just
taking the value in every element and
you're shifting it one place to the left
you can then have a feedback shift
register where the whole thing is in a
kind of a circle so when it shifts off
the right hand end it reappears at the
left hand end and then you can have more
complicated forms of feedback where
instead of just taking the one at the
end and cycling it back to the beginning
you can take for example two or three
different uh Taps on the shift register
and use some combination of the values
at those Taps to be the thing that
determines what gets shifted back in at
the left hand side for example and there
were studies of non-linear feedback
shift registered so it's a question of
how do you combine those Taps do you
just add the numbers mod 2 or do you do
something more elaborate and the more
elaborate case a person called Saul
goomb who I knew quite well uh worked on
that in the mid-1950s
um initially in connection with uh
trying to well shift registers I mean in
the end linear feedback shift registers
I think might be the most used the sort
of maximal length linear free batch
refreshister which is what soul go on
invented might be the most used
algorithm in history uh such shift
registers are used all over kind of
communication channels between displays
and computers between GPS satellites for
timing information in cellular telephony
for CDMA code division multiplexing uh
just a a gazillion uses for this
algorithm for finding a way of of
tapping into the shift register so that
you will get the maximum length before
the sequence of bits repeats
but Sogo arm also studied the nonlinear
case
um somehow in connection with various
kinds of radar timing uh kind of things
that were kind of analogous to what
happens with the GPS satellites today
which is you kind of know what the time
is by seeing whether you have a
particular piece of sequence that has a
particular form and because the sequence
has a maximum length to the N or
whatever before it repeats if you see I
have a block of length 15 that is one
zero zero one blah blah blah blah you
can figure out there's an algorithm to
tell you exactly where in the sequence
that block occurs and so it's a
convenient way to get sort of timing
information like that and so that was a
use for also was looking at not only a
shift registers didn't you know just
sort of said here are some things they
do I didn't really conclude much from
them
um and that was another origin story
another another thing was in
the 1950s so not only the three black
shift registers I should say were also
used in cryptography uh it is said that
the uh Soviet military codes were shift
register codes uh some people have said
told me that they were linear feedback
shift registers that were sort of
guaranteed to be of of long repeats and
where the the inversion of a linear
feedback should register can be done
essentially by linear algebra by
essentially Matrix and version
um but if it's a big enough register
that Matrix inversion is still quite
difficult although with modern computers
and modern in their algebra algorithms
is pretty pretty straightforward so the
nonlinear case the crypto analysis is
much harder and is probably MP complete
it's probably a good way of actually
making crypto systems and for example my
rule 30 crypto system is a little bit
like that
um but
anyway it is sometimes said that the
Soviet military codes were not any
feedback shift registers
um although I have to say I've been told
more often that they were linear
feedback registers but in any case it
was non-linear feedback trip registers
were investigated for cryptography
um particularly in the 1950s and that
was done particularly by a bunch of
mathematicians in the US who were
working for the National Security Agency
and who it's very strange in the
literature of this field that there are
all these um uh maps of the shift the
shift just means well it's kind of like
shift registers actually I haven't even
ever noticed that but it's kind of a the
story of you've got a sequence of ones
and zeros and you're kind of
progressively shifting them
um it's kind of funny actually now that
I think about it I'm not sure I ever
noticed that before because the concept
of the shift map is one in mathematics
kind of it is really doing the same
thing as a shift register in electronics
but um uh but but anyway the in the late
1950s
a bunch of very distinguished American
mathematicians University mathematicians
were consultants for the NSA and uh did
a bunch of classified work which I think
is still not not uh not Declassified
um but they also published some of their
results as these kind of mathematics
papers uh they're all about the shift
map and automorphisms as a shift and so
on and questions like when you have a
non-linear cellular automaton
effectively under what circumstances is
it reversible is it the case that every
state of the cellular automata in every
complete state maps onto a single state
so that you can invert it
well there was a big table of it of
invertible cellular automata that was
published
over our 1960 I think
um by some of these folks
and uh
um
I think well they're probably there are
a number of stories related to this
which I think are are not tellable on a
live stream yet
um the uh
um having to do with the the sort of the
interaction of of um uh of sort of the
pure mathematics with the um uh sort of
military cryptography work but in any
case the um
the things that um uh this this sort of
big table of invertible cellular
automata it was like a thing and uh it
turns out that was used in the creation
of the Des the data encryption standard
which was sort of the the standard form
of cryptography which actually has
evolved into things like AES and so on
which are standard sort of stream Cipher
block Cipher like the standard
non-public Key cryptographic Systems
that are still used today but the in Des
for example it had always been
mysterious what the so-called s-boxes
the things that substitute patterns of
bits for other patterns of bits uh what
had determined what those were
and I haven't really ever Tracked Down
exactly the correspondence between the S
boxes and that table but I'm pretty sure
that it was that study of invertible
cellular automata that led to the
decision to use particular seemingly
random sort of particular rearrangements
of bits into es so that was another kind
of origin story and I have to say I'm
not sure that origin story intersected
with any other ones until possibly some
talk that I gave uh at um
uh The Institute for defense analyzes in
in Princeton this must have been early
1980s
um and uh uh I guess the folks that had
heard about things I was doing with
cellular automata and um that was that
was a bunch of people who'd worked on
kind of uh practical cryptography and
that was a case where sort of these two
worlds collided so to speak
um but uh
it was some
um let's see I mean other I would say
that the the vast majority of work
that was done on what got called
cellular automata was two-dimensional
cellular automata a lot of things with
image processing in the 1950s
um and uh there were a lot of things
with sort of so-called picture languages
was another Branch uh just many
different branches
um I have to say that um by
the late 1970s many people sort of in
the theoretical Computer Science World
had decided everything that could be
figured out with cellular automatically
been figured out it's all over now
um it was sort of ironic that the kind
of experimental investigation of
cellular automata that I kind of started
at the beginning of the 80s was the
thing that sort of was the the
completely different very different from
sort of the theoretical discussion of
there exists a cellular automaton that
emulates a turing machine doing this or
that thing that had been the sort of the
previous
focus of work there
that was one Focus I mean another focus
at work was we've got this particular
way of taking patterns of bits and
replacing them by other patterns of bits
that is good for sharpening edges and
images or something that was again an
example of a solid automaton well
cellular autonomous and like kind of
kind of method I mean there were other
branches
um as I say it's a concept that is
simple enough that it's been invented
many times separately I mean there was a
whole branch in the Soviet Union uh
particularly a chap called the Ladies
um
um and um that was kind of somewhat more
biologically inspired I think somewhat
in the Von Neumann thread but it led was
a I mean there have been many different
branches so there was a big Soviet piece
there was a big piece in Japan that was
particularly concentrating on kind of
the somehow the intersection between
sort of the signal processing-ish
version of cellular automata and the
theoretical computer science version
um there were
oh let's see where else
um I think in the US mostly cellular
automata and researcher kind of died out
by the time most of the branches had
kind of died by the time I started
working on it in the early 80s
um but it was still alive and well in in
some other places around the world
um but that's yeah that's a rough Story
I mean there's there's more detail in my
big book new kind of science I have a
whole collection of notes about the
history of cellular automata sadly one
fact in one of those notes I believe now
to be incorrect as I've determined in
the last actually few days
um and uh having to do with uh well it
was I would argue it might not be my
fault I I spent an hour or two back in
the early 1990s kind of interviewing a
person who gave me that fact and like
are you sure was it really the state was
it Etc et cetera et cetera and uh but I
got snocket I think
um and the and the actual the actual
date is as many as after the one that I
was was given so
um you know that but that's to my
knowledge that's the only error in the
treatment of the history of cellular
automata that you'll find a new kind of
science
I'll be writing about that one soon
um
let's see well I should probably uh wrap
up here I have to go back to my day job
but a lot of interesting um
questions here I see several that
probably probably
do better in my um uh other
by
what is it is it not called bi-weekly by
yeah bi-weekly yes but every two weeks
um uh iteration of uh my uh q a about
business Innovation and managing life so
I think a few of these questions should
get moved there
um oh boy there are so many more here
that I would love to talk about and I
will um
uh
um
we'll try and do it
another time I look forward to to doing
that thank you for a lot of interesting
questions
all right should wrap up now so so bye
for now